di latte à guillaume abrite un lieu
unique à la réunion il s'agit d'un
plateau complètement isolée sur les
remparts de la rivière de saint denis en
est sur un site départementaux domaniale
le département a voulu lancer une étude
pour avoir une meilleure lisibilité sur
le site d'un point de vue historique et
aussi d'un point de vue archéologique et
l'inrap a été choisi pour faire tout
c'est cette approche
archéologiques il ya même une artiste du
secteur qui retranscrit des dessins
relatant l'histoire met en lien avec les
habitants les associations du coin c'est
important dans le travail qui est posée
ici qu'on puisse établir une relation
dans cette co construction on insiste
beaucoup sur ce fait là parce qu'il
s'agit de l'histoire de l'île est à
guillaume il s'agit de l'histoire de la
réunion et c'est important que l'on
puisse construire tous ces éléments
importants avec tous nos partenaires
l'état le département tous les
partenaires les associations et la
population à partir de 1864 les
missionnaires de la congrégation du
saint-esprit décide d'y construire une
colonie agricole pénitentiaire pour
enfants à l'image de ces maisons de
correction qui est saine partout en
france au milieu du 19e siècle à partir
de 1850 en france on installe ce qu'on
appelle les maisons de correction pour
éviter aux enfants la prison donc on va
mettre en place des lieux de placement
collectif où les enfants vont travailler
vont être isolé et on pense que grâce à
ça ils vont être dressé c'est exactement
ce que vont faire les spiritains ici
d'abord à la providence puis en créant
une annexe là-haut à lille est à
guillaume et on va y ressembler des
enfants placés par la justice des
enfants qu'il faut redresser l'état
guillaume les enfants sont gardés par
les remparts on n'a pas besoin du tout
dit architecture carcérale et pour ça
les lettres c'est absolument dans le
projet des maisons de correction et puis
c'est un lieu où les enfants ont
beaucoup travaillé on va beaucoup leur
faire construire des murs des
terrassements des routes un peu et là
aussi on est dans le projet intégral des
colonies agricoles pénitentiaire on
pense que par l' isolement et le travail
les enfants vont retrouver le bon chemin
c'est absolument pour le coup assez
inédit pour moi de travailler avec des
archéologues c'est à dire que là on va
vraiment mallet le travail en archives
et le travail sur le terrain pour
compléter le travail de l'historienne
sur les archives une équipe
d'archéologues sous la direction de
thierry cornec est chargé par le
département de la réunion de réaliser
une étude exhaustive des vestiges du
pénitencier pour cette mission un peu le
département a confié l'inrap je suis
accompagné de trois spécialistes un
topographe qui assure aussi tous les
relevés de photogrammétrie un
spécialiste de l'étude du bâti qui va
nous permettre de décrypter
les différentes constructions et une
archéobotanique pour l'évolution de la
flore sur le site les dernières il ya eu
un relevé lidar qui a été réalisé sur le
site par le département donc ceux
relevés l'ida nous donne un modèle
numérique terrestre se dire qu'on voit
le micro relief du site problème dit
d'ars et qui fait abstraction de ce qui
rend tropiques et naturel nous avons
effectivement nous voyons des terrasses
à micro relief nous on sait pas s'il a
été fait par la main de l'homme
naturellement donc nous notre hall d'un
archéologue justement c'est de
différencier ce qui est naturel ce qui
en pratique aurait si vous voyez que
toutes les terrasses son entropie
qu'elles ont été construites par ses
enfants pendant ses 15 années
d'existence du pénitencier les
informations que je vais apporter à des
collègues déjà un plan au sol pour
connaître les espaces de circulation
sous les habitats avoir des données de
curbans métriques de mesure et puis
aussi d'avoir de leur apporter des
documents sur les élévations qui vont
permettre à des collègues justement de
travailler sur ses murs et notamment
dans la partie archéo du bixi que fait
ludovic ultime clin d'oeil des meilleurs
nous permet de retracer l'histoire du
site à partir de la construction et des
méthodes de construction des murs les
archives nous parle de maçon ou des
charpentiers qui qui participait à la
mise en oeuvre du chantier mais par
contre on ne sait pas à quelle hauteur
les enfants ont travaillé ils ont pu
participer à la construction de
bâtiments de moindre importance on va
dire comme par exemple la chapelle où la
forge ou l'utilisation de blocs plus
petit est utilisée ou alors au dallage
on sait qu'ils ont participé au chemin
d'accès et à la voirie principale
ce lieu quand il était il était en
utilisation par les enfants du
pénitencier on sait qu'il y avait de
l'agriculture parce que il vivait un
petit peu en autonomie est donc on a des
témoignages des sources archives qui
nous dise qu'il y avait une agriculture
le but maintenant c'est de pouvoir
vraiment la caractériser est-ce que
c'était une grosse et l'agriculture
intensive d'une seule espèce est ce que
c'était plein de petites espèces
différentes pour répondre à cette
question je faire des prélèvements
surtout donc je creuse des sondages des
petits sondages dans lesquels je prélève
du sédiment ces sédiments ils sont
amusés et je vais rechercher les graines
et les charmants aux priorités donc ça
ça va me permettre de pouvoir dire bon à
tel endroit où j'ai prélevé on avait
télésp est à l'espèce cas d'espèce ces
trois disciplines se complètent pour
dessiner l'évolution des différentes
constructions en proposant des
chronologie relative des murs en
déterminant leur mode de construction la
mise en commun du travail des
archéologues permet de mieux comprendre
la destination de chacun des espaces
logement atelier lieux de culte
bassecourt vergers mais aussi voirie
canaux et bassins nécessaires à la
gestion de l'eau captée par la
communauté en amont du site donc on a
tous les éléments nécessaires à la bonne
compréhension du site et surtout de
s'apercevoir qu'à des pleins pleins de
choses de inédites qu'on ne connaissait
pas qu'ils avaient été vus mais mal
interprété ou pas interpréter du tout
donc au titre des nouveautés qui
voilà qu'on a découvert grâce à notre
travail d'essentiellement de nettoyage
du site le fond probablement de la
basse-cour pourquoi c'est une basse cour
puisque sur creusé dans cette danse est
terrasse on a un bassin pourquoi
s'interpréter comme un bassin deux
éléments les murs qu'on a devant nous
sont enduits pour rendre les parois et
sans doute le chemin étanche et puis
surtout sur la droite du bassin dans la
paroisse un petit peu il faudrait ici on
a on a un exutoire qui permettait
d'amener l'eau à cet endroit du site au
dessus on a à nouveau une alliée de
circulation et puis encore au dessus on
a le dernier élément d'un grand bâtiment
qui était considéré comme une partie du
logement de la communauté et à
l'extrémité les murs en élévation qui
sont cette fois ci contrairement aux
autres maçonné monter au mortier de
chaux c'est très très probablement ce
que dans les archives on a découvert
comme étant la chapelle provisoire avant
la construction de l'héliski est
construite à lens tenu du plateau la
perspective principale en fait de du
travail à venir c'est de croiser les
résultats de l'étude de terrain avec
l'étude historique de vernis blanchard
de façon à approcher au plus près la vie
des spiritains et des enfants du
pénitencier lille est à guillaume
pendant la quinzaine d'années ils ont
vécu ici
pour aller plus loin et conformément à
la mission confiée par le département de
la réunion l'inrap va proposer des
fouilles sédimentaires sur des
thématiques particulières comme les
logements de la communauté afin
d'approcher un peu plus le quotidien des
enfants et des spiritains du pénitencier
dilate à guillaume qui n'a pas fini de
livrer tous ses secrets à partir des
résultats de cette étude les
départements la réunion va pouvoir en
concertation des habitants définir un
projet de préservation et de
valorisation de ces vestiges pour le
rendre accessible à tous les réunionnais
et au-delà
anton
[Musique]